the difference between doing a sitcom
there's a camera and if something goes
wrong we take it again and I Club people
can throw bottles at you oh my god what
I opened for Aerosmith I don't see they
used to come and see me at stitches all
the time and I had no idea who they were
and someone said you know that is I said
yes some arrows me said like what a
biggest rock bands in the world I go you
know I was in the disco because it was
the dance you could get laid dance I was
up I was like I was like Travolta it is
insanity by which it was fun I mean and
I was it was crazy so they wanna stop
dance
so even when I was a fat guy I could
dance I was like Gleason you know but
they come and they said we want you to
open for a sec oh yeah no problem so uh
why go over to the Orpheum Theatre this
is what one of the many comebacks you
know after they were still getting high
thing so I mean I go in with the crowd
is going in you know and they're saying
hey me and I heard this a comedian
tonight we're gonna [ __ ] him up and I'm
listening to someone
hey man I'm the comedian it's myself
some guys Lenny money so they call me
what are you doing I said well I'm going
to him no no you go on the stage though
I don't even know they had a stage boy
so I go back in there all I mean it was
[ __ ] wild so I go on stage and they
stop fooling right over and it's like
runway lights I respect that these
incredible lights I couldn't see any and
this is but 438 did throwing bottles and
bottles are smashing all around me right
dodging [ __ ] I can't see it coming to
bite out of this lesson so this kid
throws a milk that hits me in the balls
drops me to my [ __ ] knees I'm like
it's so Steven Tyler has his body I
dragged me through the curtain cuz I'm
right by the curtain out cuz I'm I'm
backing up I'm trying to get away
hey how much we say we got a couple
granules here it is come back tomorrow
night so oh my god [ __ ] wait so I'll go
back to the next night meal [ __ ] the
Rolling Stones hours sure they don't
like a rally and I you want to go to
Japan with us I gonna see you have a
figure work around oh oh well you you
learn I think of you a good comic you
learn from your mistakes if you don't
you know you're not gonna you're not
gonna proceed and I did I had I had the
pleasure working with Rookwood who's
pretty woman who said Shakira
no no the guy who sang pretty well Oh
Roy Roy Orbison yeah I think that's how
bad my mind is I so I'm awake anymore up
for about 3 days I said I gotta go to
Woodstock open for Roy Orbison I'm
almost out of gas I'm out of blow I'm
exhausted I pull into this place and I
go up there and it's this food bigger
than this whole table all this food and
I hadn't eaten today so I just thought
Reb I'm like a bad eye on black he's got
those glasses and it's voices you did
comedian I said yeah he goes the bridge
once I do show a great show I cut back
boys you're fantastic man you want to go
on Thomas I got a Robert um yeah and I
did that work with Ray Charles you know
Wow yeah and it was so good to me oh man
it goes Lenny you're the funniest
comedian I've never seen then what the
Vegas Vegas wow it was great it was it
was amazing the only person I have all
before that I really had was juice
Newton she was such a [ __ ] to me man
yeah I was a young guy you know what I
was doing like the Cape Cod a metal tent
you know she was like a country star
write one song [ __ ] what hit
yeah uh yes here's me yeah yeah so my
buddy showed up late on my high school
okay climbed up and they took the juice
dope enough and they took the lettuce
and Lenny
oh yeah I didn't work out well yeah is
that what she was pissed about her no
she was just pissed at me I don't know I
mean if she didn't want a comedian oh
but I don't know you know I mean I was
excited about meat now you know she's a
sty no juice Newton but to play with it
okay my heart's or some [ __ ] I don't
know
she had a one big [ __ ] yeah hit a buddy
- who was in love with her he had a
juice Newton poster on his wall yeah
every time I go over his house what
elevates this time it's a long time ago
I don't even know who that guy is
anymore I remember his name it was Mike
you know who opens up for Metallica is
Brewer oh yeah yeah tours with them and
apparently he's [ __ ] sensational oh
yeah he's a big Metallica fan yes and he
does a game show yeah he's so good he's
great I love he's one of the most
underrated guys ever really he's just so
he doesn't give a [ __ ] no